Candy truth. So, have you guys ever
wondered why certain religions have this
head covering, this small little hat
that goes on the crown of your head? And
yet, there are so many of them. There's
the Muslims, there's the Catholics, and
then there's Jews. Why is it that they
all have this in common?
The interesting part is that you will
realize
that the Bible doesn't mention or
endorse men covering their heads at all.
And later I'll be sharing that verse
with you. But historically speaking, the
practice of this comes from Talmudic
times. The Talmud is the central text of
rabbitic meaning rabbi Judaism and the
primary source of Jewish religious law
and Jewish theology. During this
talmodic time, it was said that Antious
Epipanis, a Seucid emperor, wanted to
make his entire empire conform to the
Greek culture. He was obsessed with it,
and that was his personal goal. So, he
did so. But, ironically, there was the
Makabian revolt that occurred because of
his pushing the Greek culture onto the
Jews. Further during his reign and this
Talmudic period, there's a high priest
that came on the scene named Jason. He
also seemed to be in favor of the
worship of all of the Greek gods over
anything else. So, he instituted
sacrifices and offerings and games being
played in gymnasiums to the gods. He was
the one who introduced the Greek hat.
Interestingly enough though, the ancient
depiction of the hat of Hermes, if you
remember, is not that different from
this Greek hat, except for the fact that
it had wings on each side. Further, the
article states that it is estimated that
the Israelites learned this from the
Egyptians as the Egyptians wore their
hair cropped really short or shaved with
a crown shaped hat on their heads in the
form of a circle surrounding the head.
These are called kipas. And kipas are
what Jewish people wear today. But let's
freeze there because what if? Just what
if the wearing of these tiny small hats
that go over the crown of your head and
usually have several radiating pieces of
fabric, they're kind of like sun rays.
What if they have to do with sun
worship? Because it is kind of
symbolizing that you worship the sun.
Could it just be that that is something
going on here? Here's where we get into
the Bible and what the Bible has to say
about it. It says in 1 Corinthians 11:7,
"For a man indeed ought
not to cover his head, for as much as he
is the image and glory of Elohim." That
is one text. But what about another?
This is in Deuteronomy 12:30 and
31 where he says, "Take heed to yourself
that you are not ins snared to follow
them after they are destroyed from
before you and that you do not inquire
after their gods, saying, "How did these
nations serve their gods? I also will do
likewise. You shall not worship the Lord
your God in that way. For every
abomination to the Lord, which he hates,
they have done to their gods. For they
burn even their sons and daughters in
the fire to their gods. This is what
would appear to be synchronized pagan
worship. Just a little bit of a side
note, they usually all have a string of
beads as well, aka think the rosary. So
why would they all have that? So let's
go into this a little bit more here.
This is from Egypt tours portal. It says
in the worship of Syel, she was a
goddess. They had what were galley
priests. I've spoken about this in my
entire show on androgyny if you'd like
to go watch that. It's very
enlightening. But these galley priests
were unic priests dedicated to the
goddess Sael known in Rome as Magna M.
Their rituals involved self-castration
as a profound act of devotion. Post
initiation they dawned women's clothing
including yellow robes and adorned
themselves with jewelry, turbins and
heavy makeup. They also wore a type of
crown. Here we go. possibly laurel
wreath and gold bracelets known as
oabus. Their attire and rituals
including ecstatic dances and self
flagagillation were integral to their
worship practices. Yes, the practices of
shaving the head and wearing specific
head coverings such as small round hats
are historically associated with sun
worship and consecration to
deities embodying solar attributes. In
ancient cultures, including Egypt and
the cult of Syel, these rituals and
attire symbolized devotion to the
divine. I mentioned Hermes before, so
let's take a look at Hermes.
Hermeticism, a spiritual and
philosophical tradition rooted in the
teachings of Hermes. Tris megasus, a
syncric figure combining elements of the
Greek god Hermes and the Egyptian god
Thoth, places significant emphasis on
the sun as a central symbol of divine
knowledge and illumination. Now, Alistar
Cwley was all about Thoth. He had Thoth
tarot cards that he sold. He was into
it. He wanted to connect with that god.
A website called the digital amler
states, first of all, the heading is
setting up a hermetic shrine. Their
information on the fact that wearing one
of these hats is important in hermetic
practices and rituals comes straight
from one of their occult sources on how
to actually set up your altar or shrine
to one of these gods or Hermes himself.
So that's what I have for you guys
today. I hope that you liked it. Please
like, subscribe, and share this
information. I will see you guys next
time. Candid truth.
[Music]